and you notice that i've got some
crutches behind me um
that's the main reason i'm shooting this
update video
about a week ago actually it is almost a
week ago to the to the hour
i injured my my lcl my uh lateral
lateral collateral ligament which is
kind of a mouthful
out at the beach with my with my
children
we were out in the surf at montauk and
you know it's always the wave that you
don't see that that gets you and i went
down and something
thankfully didn't tear just sprained but
i came up and and
it's kind of a a scary thing for a few
minutes
and
but you know good good treatment and all
that and so i'm not getting around very
well um you notice i'm sitting down
shooting uh in my office
i don't think i'll be up in front of the
chalkboard for at least another month
so what that means practically speaking
is there won't be any new core concept
videos or course videos or doctors have
their chalk and talks for for at least
the next month or so i'm supposed to
use these to to get around and keep the
the weight off of my my left foot and
the knee as much as possible keep it
elevated keep it keep it iced
and as i am a person who who does have
other things besides shooting videos to
do
that means that everything else takes
quite a bit more time
and
got to find the time somewhere so i
won't be shooting any of the doctors out
of the chalk and talk
the core concept or the course videos
for a while i will however be shooting a
lot more of the personal videos you know
some of the things about the different
phases i went through in my development
as a philosopher somebody asked me an
interesting question about languages
that i'll respond to
i think it's overdue that i talk a
little bit more about the prison
teaching and
other things that people might be
interested in so if you if you actually
have some topics
that you're particularly interested in
now would be a good time to either put
them in the comments or send me a
message
now i'm shooting this video in part as
an update because i'm sure you know i've
got something like four thousand odd
viewers at this point
and most of them have uh
four thousand subscribers most of them
have no idea you know what happened with
my lag
or anything like that i have a facebook
page and the people who who consult that
they've known about why i haven't been
doing very much for the last week
for a while but i didn't put any
announcement on on youtube perhaps i
should have
since i know people look forward to
these these videos
in any case um
you can expect to see some more personal
videos coming out if that's not your
thing maybe you know tune out for a
little while and wait until i start
talking about aristotle and plato and
augustine and that sort of thing again
but if that is the sort of thing that
you're interested in um you could stay
tuned so
let me think if there's anything else to
tell you about oh yeah so so the uh the
injury
it was really kind of strange
we were we were in the surf and it was
high tide
and um kind of an overcast day i'm gonna
be actually shooting another video or
putting together another video some of
the shots that i got that day some
beautiful shots of the ocean
and you know the waves were rolling in
we were trying to to wash off the sand
from our bodies because we'd done the
thing where each one of us you know got
buried up to our our head of the sand
but then there's lots of sand on us and
we're getting ready to pack up
so i was out in the
the waves and they didn't seem like they
were that high but you know i turned my
attention away
from the waves for for just you know
short short period of time
and i got i got washed over
and hit by them
and i went down and
i'm not sure exactly what happened i
know that as i was coming up it could be
that you know current was pulling
one way or pushing one way or something
like that and that my foot landed in the
wrong way but i felt something given my
my knee now when you're a guy in your
40s that's definitely not something that
you want to feel i mean it hurt to begin
with
but it's interesting because
it was it was scary not because of the
pain i mean i've felt much worse pain
before
different injuries and things like that
burns in particular
but um it was scary because i could you
could feel this you know you could feel
the knee joint slipping or giving or
something like that and you know that
something like that is a bad injury
so
that's um
that's what was going on i got myself
out of the the surf because you know i'm
strong enough with my arms to like you
know pull myself
but my my my knee was basically useless
i tried to get up and put weight on it
and it just crumpled up and again it was
painful but it was it was scarier
because of the way it just sort of
gave out
so i had to
get myself out of the surf luckily my my
wife was close by and she could help you
know get me out
and then it was a question of getting me
back up to you know where the uh the
towels and all of our our gear was so we
could start thinking about what's going
on what are we going to do
and
i i got to say everybody at montauk was
was really helpful
you know the first responders um the
people at the hotel that we were staying
helped out
and uh they were very generous actually
they they switched our rooms so we could
stay in a
lower room
so i wouldn't have to go up the stairs
because by then it was starting to to by
the time that i got back from the
hospital was starting to hurt
so you know
it was pretty clear i had to go to the
hospital and we got we got me off the
beach
or rather they got me off the beach
and
got me into an ambulance and the whole
time
it really wasn't hurting that bad
unless i did certain things
and i was more worried about whether i
damaged anything within the knee whether
it was going to be one of those sort of
cases where
it could actually impair my my walking
because again
when you're in your 20s you can take all
sorts of injuries i got i got injured in
a lot of different ways you just bounce
back fairly quick when you're in your
40s it takes a lot longer to heal
and knee injuries are bad and you know
that and i come from a family of trades
people so lots of people with with bad
knees you know a lot of people actually
having their knees replaced
so
you know i didn't really want to think
about those those sorts of things
so i got to the hospital they ran the
x-rays uh they got it done fairly
quickly everybody was pretty nice
and the verdict was it's a sprain so i
just have to take it easy which is kind
of tough for me because i'm a person who
likes to get things done
got these crutches to get around on i've
already worn out the first uh set of
crutch tips
meaning these things here
taking my son
to
ride a train a cowboy train and i'll
tell more about that in another video
but i had to go on gravel for a bit and
actually the the crutch tips that i have
now they've got a little metal piece in
here that keeps the metal from from
breaking through
but the stuff that they gave me
originally just had plastic there
and a big guy like me
uh going a good ways on gravel with uh
with his son in tow you can imagine i
tore them up pretty pretty bad and then
i was starting to slip around on other
things
so
um
this is kind of an impediment but uh
you know this is the sort of stuff that
life throws at you i'm fortunate enough
that i've got good medical care that i
didn't tear it
and that it's actually what i think is a
you know fairly uh
easy ligament to heal compared to some
of the other ones i didn't tear any any
other stuff i just sprained it
so with with some
some rest
and
slowing down a little bit on the work
and and getting around places
everything should be good as new within
a
month or so
in any case uh getting back to the video
stuff um like i said
if you've got a particular interest in
something that you'd like me to talk
about that doesn't involve me getting up
in front of the chalkboard which i i
can't do for a while
let me know and i will
consider shooting the video
there's a lot of other things to to
start
working on
and
there's my my summary of what's coming
up for the next month